l tour in questo nuovo video sono fa vj
è passata ragazzi la febbre quindi
riesca di registrare con un cristiano
normale normale si fa per dire
ovviamente i ragazzi nel mentre che sono
stato via mi hanno detto che è uscito un
gioco horror per la crus riff che era da
tanto che non usciva una roba così
proviamo tanto son contento di fa ste
cose per carità di dio
eccoci qua siamo sua è una demo questa
non sapevo fosse una demo una bella
partenza dai vogliamo riuscire a fare
una roba decente press spacebar dai
scout perché sono mondo perché ho i
piedi sexy perché come cazzo noi la
[ __ ] c'è cazzo è ragazzi oddio ho
spaccato tutto per ri a salve allora
ascolta in ascoltami ascoltami listerine
e l'alito migliore zio ma te lo posso
giurare dite che gli è piaciuta la
limonata
e orribile è la cosa più immersiva che
abbia mai fatto
a parte ciao signò che avrò la madonna
che boccia se tu puoi toccarmi e poi
tocca consegue la roba lì a 6 la
parrucchiera ascolta una spuntatina qui
è proprio solo qui non ti azzardare
guarda che ho avuto la febbre ieri su
cazzi tuoi
ma quali non so i miei capelli zia
quello che è il mio pancreas lo vuoi ma
basta chiedere i capelli sono qua non la
pancia di ritagliarmi ho detto quindi ma
si [ __ ] brava brava qui e qui
proprio qua
questo piano piano piano
checlasse
cioè mi ha vomitato in faccia e
riesplosa la testa questa sì ma non è
che mo torna colori prega piano è posso
alzarmi da questa cazzo di seiano è
perché sono venuto perché so che vi sta
spingendo perché sto andando avanti
ragazzi chi è che mi stavi posso
guardare dietro per cortesia non posso
guardare
devo andare avanti va bene e andiamo
avanti bel pavimento e su tutto
bellissimo complimento è ben salde hai
detto qualcosa zio ci si lamentano
perché tali val cerfone tutti a nanna
ragazzi tutti a nanna e guai a chi siamo
ho detto la petite i giocatori ball
detto bravo bravo bravo ne manca uno se
ti muovi non sei nessuno
i miei ragazzi regali miei ragazzi che
bravi che sono no rega sono aracnofobia
cortesia potete mettere qualsiasi cosa
nella vita tranne questi cazzo ragazzi
mi sputa giuro che mia madre non è
possibile
usciamo da questa merda grazie percorsi
no e chi cazzo sei de schiacciati da
inizio brass caccia li scacciano i
partiti don 50 euro che ti taglio anche
i baffi se hai voglia se vuoi perché non
stai bene in realtà ne vai e vieni qua
subito chiamata gli arti baffi caccia
con gli schifosi di merda
no no no frate quello non non è una
piscina quella li
vabbè dai farfa il tuffo bomba facciamo
così ti aiuto io aspetta che ti spingo
spingo dentro proprio aspetta un attimo
che sei corpi cadono corpi cosa fa la
mano svolta se ti sfido io oggi se vinco
io fermo ancora un po che bravo
bravissimo lo abbiamo aiutato a
migliorare la sua vita ragazzi non ho
ancora capito che mi sto spinge sì però
se vai un po più a sinistra magari non
cado cadono carcasse di capre morte nel
nevada è bello comunque è stato il
pollice in su ragazzi per il doppio del
nostro amico che era niente male e
finito e io smetterei di spingere la
smetterei di spingere basta per frena
frena frena frena cam ignota non uno
scotto zio mi frena ecco bravo bilancio
col culo
siamo indietro ecco io non ho ancora
capito che è che dei piedi ogni volta
che li vedo in una moro di più di me
stesso cos'è sta roba
una bollicina
si è successo si sta riempiendo la
stanza di acqua ma è acqua o il sangue
non lo so che cosa sia ma va bene così
perché se cadevo era una merda sto
bilanciando solo col mio culone ciao
frate ascoltano se la mio cari prima non
sono no no no ai capelli sono qui sono
quanto sei hai finito di ascoltarmi
perché poi non muoio io sono in corso no
iron man
bello grazie lo stesso la mancia ma va
bene così che bello il bagnetto che così
mi pulisco tutto lo schifo
il fantastico ecco che so anche montare
a rana cazzo ti facendo spietato ci sono
cose che vola non ho capito cos'è sta
bollicina ragazzo
vabbè io parlo sott'acqua sono tipo nemo
però non ho capito perché devo fare il
bagno la mamma non mi ha detto niente
ragazzi però frate a quanto segno o
questa è un'altra no carica ascolta zia
se sei molto bella c'è qualcosa alla
bocca non ho capito che cos'è però sei
bella sicuramente bella e senti io non
posso tenere il respiro più di tanto che
però fatti la ceretta e un pochettino se
sei molto gnocca no mi guardare così che
madonna arriva al destro
sto scherzando è se non sai che io
scherzo spesso su ste cose
la chicca tra noi ha succhiato è mica un
po a dieta però è potresti metterti
vabbè è finito finito così come fa esser
finito così ma dai è comunque io la tipo
alla fine una bottarella quindi ragazzi
questo è il vero finale del gioco
credetemi non l'ho cambiato i cori prima
c'è questa tizia che era la tipa ciao
perché parli come se ti avessero
infilato una trota nel culo questa
action nemico ciao
dimmi qualche parola di conforto ti
prego no bisogno
dobbiamo continuare così pertanto zia
cioè non è che potete cazzo è quella
roba lì c'è una razza o dio
oddio oddio sto andando io sto andando
zia
seguimi de anche tu puoi camminare
sull'acqua è nostro non solo io gesù il
cammino sull'acqua tu non cammina in su
e c'è una roba che è caduta in acqua e
fatemi andare a podio cioè razzi a
propulsione nel culo che figo cosa si
trova sul nuovo che forza
cos'è c'è una roba eh io io cammino
sull'acqua lei cammina sotto sono poi
sono punti di vista ragazzo ognuno al
suo a parte contemplare le palme spesa
giri la testa
[Musica]
quindi mi parlavi della guerra di
secessione ma ragazzi ha capito verso
nuovi orizzonti
andiamo a trovare il one piece vincerà
chi ha più formaggio mi sembra una cosa
molto romantica concludere con il
tramonto sul mare che minchia di
tramonto sto parlando che manco ce ne
parla è stata una esperienza di vita da
fare credete che comunque ragazzi sono
che un pentolino aver più la febbre
perché ho potuto riscoprire le gioie del
videogame proprio per ea spero che vi
sia piaciuto cose così video è piaciuto
lasciato un punto è un mi piace o mi
piace se anche voi volete una
parrucchiera così gnocca come quella di
prima poi lasciate il mi piace io chiamo
e dico questo ha lasciato mi piace vai a
tagliare i capelli con garbo è
tranquilli che gli insegna se serve si
discrete cv diavolo possibili
e da rialzi